it's been called one of the greatest
questions of our time
[Music]
are we alone
in the universe
using advanced research techniques and
cutting-edge technology matt walsh seeks
to answer this question once and for all
aliens
who are they
where do they come from
do they know
what a woman is
do they even
exist
over the years many people have said
they were visited in some cases abducted
by these
beings from outer space
but is there enough evidence to back up
their claims
i'm on a mission to investigate these
alleged alien encounters and if i can
bring back evidence proving once and for
all that e.t is real the first stop on
this journey took me to lincoln new
hampshire and the site of the first
widely publicized alien abduction in
american history in all my many minutes
as an alien hunter
i never expected what we found
on march 1 1639 the governor of
massachusetts bay colony john winthrop
recorded the details of what would
become the first alien sighting in
american history
going back as far as ancient egypt we
find evidence of humans looking to the
stars for signs of celestial neighbors
over the years as technology and
communication have evolved our
understanding of alien life forms has
changed as well
[Music]
i'm gonna build a spaceship
i need it for my day trip
it's gonna be great
it's gonna be
[Music]
yeah i think back to uh
it's our early
childhood and my
first experience hearing about aliens
was from movies you know
from from hollywood
in a certain way that has
shaped probably my impression of of
aliens but i don't think that that at
all
discredits you know
the fact that aliens exist one of the
things i'm hoping to
to find when we get to
the the spot here
is well obviously i'm expecting given
that it was such a
historic event monuments statues a
museum like all kinds of stuff like that
uh and that's gonna be very fascinating
but the other thing i'll tell you what
i'm looking for is
evidence like little breadcrumbs because
you hear about these cases where the
aliens come down and they leave
little things behind
and sometimes they can be there for
years and no one notices them so that's
one thing i'm i'm hoping to find
i actually had a friend
this is true
uh
who
went to there's a different alien
sighting and he found
sort of like metallic
material
and i said do what you're thinking which
is
is that just aluminum foil
and he said no it's way different
and i said how is it different and he
leaned in closer and he
way different
that's all i needed to hear
that's the kind of evidence we're
dealing with
[Music]
many alien sightings like the one
described by john winthrop would come to
be documented over the years but none
like the curious case of betty and
barney hill
the first widely publicized report of an
alien abduction in american history
barney and betty
hill very credible witnesses
interracial couple you know
makes it vaguely racist to disbelieve
them to begin with
and the story they tell
has the ring of truth to it september 19
1961 betty and i were returning from a
vacation trip in canada
close to 9 30 o'clock p.m
and we stopped in a small town border
town called coldbrook new hampshire
and we had a refreshment with coffee and
betty called my attention to uh
an object he had been watching they see
lights up around the moon
and started to come in towards
our car when it started coming towards
us this is when we returned to the car
and
made the comment that he had seen us and
was coming towards us as they're driving
they stop they get out of the car
and this orb
sort of floats down
and there are
figures
inside this craft that actually are
waving to them
with the binoculars i can concern what i
call our figures moving about because
the object was tilted
at a slight angle
that would have enabled the occupants to
look down yes that's correct so think
about it these aliens they came all the
way from the moon to go and talk to
barney and betty hill
which is pretty polite i think very nice
of them
and then they just get up and leave
never to be seen
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you